all right humans
avatars and other assorted creatures of
the internet it is january 29th i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report
direct message live from blaze tv
studios here in dallas texas look at me
do i look like a free man isn't there a
lightness that you can see i feel
free welcome to texas i am in texas with
blaze
tv hosts you know them you love them
glenn beck stu bergery sarah gonzalez
first time for
you guys that's burger and nobody can
ever say no i thought i was so we always
say no we always
everybody always introduces them and and
it's a new way every time
i i only have one thing on the prompter
which is the name
even though i know your name but that's
not i mean yeah
it is that's what it spells but it
doesn't look like that this year this is
every time i got called to the nurse's
office back in the i actually
intentionally did that because i was
trying to give you a little more
cultural significance like
some sort of we have a foreigner with us
otherwise canadian
spy otherwise they're gonna say i got
just well gonzalez
but still it's like oh no
i've been told i'm white passing so
white passing yeah
it's actually golden sails
neck is great only nazis would be able
to
pronounce a german name correct
all right guys these are my notes today
i got i got nothing because i thought if
i can't figure out what to talk to you
guys about for a half hour then i'm
i'm not worth my salt so we are in a
crazy time
i i've done shows with all you guys in
the last couple days about everything
so i'm going to start this away from
politics specifically like how are you
feeling just
generally about the state of the world
because i think that's what most people
are thinking about like they're looking
at the game stop thing
they're looking at the executive actions
they're looking at the lockdowns
and it and for the average person which
i only consider myself an average person
it's like it all adds up to your life
how are you feeling just like the state
of the world right now so uh i feel like
we're getting closer and closer to a
national divorce
quite frankly i know i know glenn here
talks about civil war a lot and i
have to hope that it doesn't come to
that but the more
you know i every day there's just
something that's more and more divisive
that comes out from you know the leaders
of our country
and it's it's a scary time i was just
telling them off here you know i have a
four month old baby and i said who's
here
yes who's here who's here who traveled
with me this is like full working mom
right now
and um i look at him every day and i'm
like
was this the time to have a baby you
know that's right
yes so we think can you can you go
expand on that a little bit
um yeah if if you've ever lived in my
head which stu will tell you you don't
want because
he's been there since 1997 and he's
that's why
i mean therapy like crazy um it's a dark
place where we're headed um and and i
have to tell you that
i i believe in god
um but i also believe in man
he will find a way to survive in the
worst
and we are i mean if you think of what
people went through in
poland and they i mean real
oppression real gulags all these things
we're talking about digital gulags
they found a way to communicate they
found a way
to um spread the message
they found a way we're not even close to
that and i think that
with what we saw with wall street that's
telling a lot of the people
especially the people who watched their
parents
go through 2008 maybe lost their
business lost their house
whatever lost a lot lost their jobs and
they saw the big banks being bailed out
then they they've seen it again with
kovid all the big guys get bailed out
but mom and dad lost their jobs lost
their
fortune you know those people who have
seen that
they know it's the big players and that
are the problem
and when you tell them directly
you can't win you can't win because we
will
we will take away your tools the
20-somethings are not people like
me who i'm like trying to figure out the
remote control
they will find a way in and we will have
a new birth of freedom
that will actually mean something again
because
my generation doesn't know what
real freedom is and we don't certainly
know what real captivity is
well the irony of course is that when
the young people
find those new means of freedom which is
exactly what happened with the robin
hood app they were finally getting in on
the game
the system comes in and literally shuts
down the app
shuts down the groups you'll have to
shut down the entire internet it's like
bitcoin
you're never going to get rid of it
how are you feeling on that uplifting
note uh he he's always inspiring i was
uh
always makes me happy that was the best
that was my best
shot guy it all goes downhill from there
at the end you'll never
succeed okay okay no no i mean you meant
that they'll never
they'll never shut yes freedom down
um i think you know you could look at
the world and see an unending hellscape
pretty easily uh i think the best way to
answer that question though is
to make your world smaller you know the
small when you like
we were on vacation over christmas break
and i really like i did i almost pulled
a reuben
i almost went fully i did you should
yeah and i try to disconnect as much as
i can and you know this better than
anybody
you pull yourself out of this world and
you start thinking about your family and
your friends and the things you enjoy
it it it's easy to feel and understand
that this is actually a really great
time to be alive right i mean it really
is
it is it's the greatest time to be alive
if any of us
could be you know up in a pre-mortal
world
and they could say anytime any place
from the creation to
2021 where and when would you want to be
born
it'd be right now right here maybe 2019.
yes yes those are the 2019 is the good
old days yeah those days don't come back
bizarre situation we're in um do you
think we have to just totally rethink
our relationship with big tech that we
had this thing for 20 years that was
free except it took our souls and now
finally we're realizing
oh yeah what was cool 20 years ago about
reconnecting with your
you know seventh grade friend now you
realize that in essence
you hate them or they hate you because
of some political issue which is to your
point about local
you hate them over something that
neither one of you have any
power over yeah i do think that you're
right we are at a crossroads
roads where we need to figure out what
you know what big tech looks like
from now you know going down the road
but i think that the problem is going to
be uh
what kind of hands government has in
that right
because they're yeah there you go yes
this is severe
i did that that was 2018 2019
it says 19 underneath it i mean look at
it now yeah
now when i first painted that remember
people were like what does that
represent
now you look at it and you're like oh i
got it got it yeah yeah i mean
and i think that no go ahead well i was
just going to say we look at who's in
charge right now
and i know i don't want these people
creating policies
for big tech and what's going to happen
from now you know 10 years from now
that's terrifying so i think it all
boils down to
you know what what role the government
has in that
and i go back to what i just said on i
don't know what's happening to me i'm
very hopeful all of a sudden but i go
back to what i was saying
a minute ago that it's you know
jefferson said
it's wrong of us to impose our will
at the end of our life on the next
generation every generation needs to
choose it for themselves that's why they
had the amendments
and that ability in the constitution
because another generation come and say
those are old ideas i don't like it
let's change these things um
the next generation is not
the hippie generation which is now in
charge the people the hippies from the
60s
they're just grabbing on and they're
holding with everything that they have
and forcing it down everybody's throat
it's not my generation
it's not a it's not a matter of
regulation deregulation
it's not a matter of who's in power
we're entering a completely new time
where the internet and technology
will either be the greatest slave master
or the biggest moses and you know dave
i started the blaze in 2010 because i
saw this coming
we were just way too early um the time
is right now but at least we have the
infrastructure but we don't have all of
it yeah
you are working on really we're working
on
really important tech and together all
of us are working
on even more important tech down the
road that
you know may take five or ten years and
billions of dollars
but that's the secret if if if
we can have enough time and enough
brains
uh and um enough people that
see a greater good than just getting
rich
putting something together then
we win because the reason why
tech is in so in such large and in
charge
is because they buy or destroy everybody
who competes with them
so yet we got to stop that we have to be
dedicated to do it and quietly build it
and we'll dismantle oppression
not only not only buy and destroy but as
we've talked about with robin hood
they will destroy themselves yeah in in
the name of it
so since you're sitting next to hopeful
glenn beck how many hours do you guys do
in the studio together a day three hours
four hours
uh three hours three three hours four
hours are you
feeling the hopelessness like do you
think there's enough time
for us to figure out some of the
technological police answers more than
me
i know how much hopefulness i can deal
with on one show
you know i think there's a uh i am
really optimistic about a lot of this
stuff you know i mean i
i'm a big believer in free markets and i
do think that they generally speaking
provide the solutions
there's a there's a level of government
crackdown that can stop that
but like you know the question you
brought up about how much
how much involvement do we want
government involved in big tech is such
an
interesting and difficult one for
conservatives in particular
because we all see what they're doing
and it's wrong
and we can all stand up and say that
this is wrong they're silencing these
voices
and there's that temptation to go and
say like you know maybe legislation's
the right way to go this is
these people are such bad actors we have
to do something but i go back to
something that's
that happened just as biden was taking
um office
which was uh you know aoc that's right
everything was cured
right uh you know aoc and others were
talking about what happened you know uh
over january 6 and they were of course
tying it to
every conservative that ever wanted low
taxes and talking about how we have to
shut these media sources down
and and and and find ways to expand
the fcc to do these things and all this
and it reminded me of when trump
was in office and he was arguing for uh
for
a widening of the libel laws um and
all of us would agree that people were
lying about donald trump 100
but if he was successful in that effort
then how would aoc
be using that today oh yeah we always
lose when we give the government more
power
and because we're on the side of freedom
actual
freedom that is fair for everyone that
you're
judged you're judged on the merits of
the case not who you are not how much
money you have
it's blind justice we believe in that
so any time you add more and more
regulation blind justice loses so so
we're
able to they're able to manipulate it so
this is what we talked about on your
show
right over there a few minutes ago so
what do you do if we all believe in
freedom okay and i think most people i
actually think if most people
truly understood the issues and if you
if they really could distill how they
live their lives
actually most people live and let live i
think it's just that we have this small
minority of hysterical people
amplified by algorithms and media that
just keeps us all crazy
but for those of us that live that way
what do you do
in a time when the other people don't
when the when
even if it's not a ton of people but the
machinery just keeps
moving on you bonhoeffer is that you
yeah exactly wrestled with we talked
about this on my show
when i was last in the studio so but
what do you do what do you do i mean
it's a good question i think that you
know you just have to keep
keep keep on keeping on for lack of a
better term i mean i know that's kind of
an
old tired phrase but um
you know that you know big tech well let
me take for instance
uh i know someone who is also a police
tv host elijah shafer
he's been getting hit recently a lot on
you know
many things but one being that he's
sharing real facts real statistics about
what is going on in the biden
administration about the jobs that are
being lost and he's really getting hit
hard by big tech
uh for you know missing context or
whatever the case may be
um and you know it you gotta you gotta
keep on
getting the word out you gotta keep on
living your life you've got to
um be secure in the in the idea
that freedom is i think an innate
concept i think we
we are born you're not born thinking
that you should be
ruled by you know big government or um
you know slave to someone else i think
that
freedom is this innate concept within us
and i think as
as long as we're you know the louder we
vocalize that the louder we vocalize
um these ideas that i think everyone can
relate to
i think it will become easier to talk to
one another because i i think that
people on the other side are very caught
up in the idea
that everyone who is a conservative is
racist
and homophobic and xenophobic and all of
the phobics
and we are becoming the exact opposite
right we are starting to believe
that everybody on the left yes and this
is a marxist communist that wants to put
us
behind yes so i think that but i think
that the more that we talk about these
ideas of you know
being free i mean that should be
something that we can all talk about
that we can all agree on and i think the
louder we are about those types of ideas
maybe the more it will resonate with the
other side
yeah what do you think about that if
you're generally a freedom loving person
how do you hold your stake in the ground
and say and do exactly what you said
before which is okay
i'm going to focus on my local community
i'm going to focus on my family that
sort of thing if the other guy
is just always moving on you yeah it's
very first of all it's very difficult
and we stay
and we fight in all of these arenas as
hard as we can um
you know it's interesting though like
when you look at the kind of
conservative worldview generally right
like
what do we think the best thing to do
for a policy is right
it's not go to the federal government
and have them come up with this grand
idea that that you know that controls
all of it it's it's local communities
and all the way down to the smallest
community being your family right
um we tend to when we get into political
conversations go up to that high level
um to try to think of like what's the
right sort of
grand unifying theory that will like let
all of our little blocks come into place
around the country
and we're seeing i think like you see
during covid a great example of localism
working right florida and texas are
running their states a hell of a lot
differently
than california is i know you painfully
are aware that i had dinner outside
well i was actually inside but i met
some people outside and we went inside
last night it was incredible
how did that feel it was very
on another planet foreign i have dinner
with you what four weeks ago yeah about
a month ago and you were like a space
alien walking in
you were like i don't know what to do
yeah you came and sat in the first thing
you said was people are just
out being and i'm like yeah it's called
america
you're sitting at the table you were by
yourself in first week i walk in i'm
look i'm like wandering trying to find
you you're sitting at the table you got
your diet coke
you're reading very relaxed i'm walking
in like my god is this real yeah
it was like we were all disney
animatronics yeah audio animatronics
yeah they've really that glenn beck
one's really good that's really good
um so you so you think just you just
keep doing that
and then and then is is it hope really
at the end that that their thing burns
out because it's not
right it's not just it's not good but we
have to keep fighting it like you know
and i think there's separate things too
we talked to a guy from the convention
of states project this week
they're in the middle of putting
together what they're calling the stack
yeah and this is a stack from beginning
to end
to you know all of the services not just
you know an app
right like this is every service from
you know getting on the internet
generally at the beginning isps servers
everything from beginning to end to make
sure that conservative voices can
actually be heard
i do think that's a difficult thing we
are all so used to these big services
i think that's part of it but i mean
generally speaking like you're not
we can elections can be moved by twitter
right um
i think fundamental principles that last
a very long time
come down from how you teach your
children right
how your how your communities are are
educating
uh kids how your communities thrive you
know
all together people working together in
in those small groups
and that i think right like texas isn't
texas because
you know i i generally speaking have
good things to think about greg abbott
like you know some people
are running against him uh in our
company um but uh but like you know
generally speaking i like texas i like
the way it's run but that doesn't come
from greg abbott
right that comes from the people who are
who
prize freedom and it comes from a lot of
people now who like us
who were living in the northeast and
said we got to get the hell out of here
and get down there
life this is a different nation than
people in the northeast i have friends
in the northeast who went out to dinner
just the other night
in eight degree weather outdoors
outdoors
long johns winter coats sweaters still
freezing
which by the way then they build outdoor
things that technically become indoor
things
they build these ridiculous things by
the way i'm glad to hear that you allow
a little descension in the ranks people
don't have to vote for the same people
that's uh yeah
you really don't know i've loosened up
on that before it was my way or the
highway
you mentioned uh you mentioned your
belief in god before and i i've said on
the show many times in last year i
am more of a believer now than i've ever
been in my adult life and i don't think
it's disconnected from all of this oh
it's not
yeah can you talk about that a little
bit because i do sense that
that having belief is connected to the
way you view government
so there's a great book by ben
sherwood um called uh venture wood right
yeah yeah
ben sherwood called survivor's club
yes i need a guy that sits next to me i
know well we've been together for so
long
it came out around 2009 or 10 somewhere
in that area
it's fantastic what he did was he went
around
and he looked at people who had survived
massive trauma whether it was a plane
crash
an economic crash whatever it was
massive trauma
how did the who were the survivors
and he found those who have faith in
something bigger than themselves
something a higher power of some sort
they survived the other ones don't
because they just go dark inside and
they just see
no way out no way to survive those who
believe that there is a connection so
me personally i've talked to penn
jillette as good friend of mine
um you know atheist and um and
and i've said to him you know penn you
could be right in the end
we don't know you could be right but if
this
makes me live a more hopeful positive
life i'm all in you know and so it that
plays a role
but when you nietzsche was right
it wasn't celebratory when he said god
is dead it was a warning
to the germans you're ki you've
killed god and once you've killed god
man will replace that with something
and in their case it was science
technology and then fascism
um and we're headed down the same road
we now worship
experts who get everything wrong three
months before
and then we say to them oh teach us
again oh expert right don't wear masks
now wear a mask now wear three masks now
stay home
just is there any evidence of this i i
don't know i'm the expert
i just did a podcast with uh avi loeb
who is
harvard astrophysicist um and he's
fascinating i mean his credentials go on
for a page and a half the guy is
brilliant and we were taught he just
wrote a new book it just came out this
week called extraterrestrial
forget about the fascinating crazy stuff
that he talked about about
extraterrestrial life and evidence of
that
but he's his main point if you read his
book
he's also making the point that
science has grown so arrogant
that they won't question things they'll
talk about
multi-verses there's no evidence of a
multiverse at this love the multiverse
there's speculation it answers some
questions but we don't have any
evidence of it we have hard
evidence of extraterrestrial life
right now the pentagon has come out with
it in the last couple of years
it's it's phenomenal what we know
but they won't question and he talks
about basically the same thing that
eisenhower
warned us about in his farewell address
which was
you're going to start to have people
that are not
driven by curiosity in science and
education
but instead are are driven by money
who will fund how can i get money how
can i get prestige
and curiosity will be gone curiosity in
our society
is gone and we talked i mean here i'm
yesterday a god guy talking to a an
astrophysicist
about god and i said you know he said
we've lost our curiosity and i said i
think that was the point of jesus
jesus said come to me as a child
and you'll have everlasting life come to
me as a child
well anybody who has a child what's the
one question they always ask what's the
one thing they always say
why why why you get to a point where
you're like
because it is that way okay why
that's what we've lost we've lost an
awe of what time we live in the things
that we can do
i believe we're going to cure cancer in
the next 10 years cure it
it'll be eradicated we've just wiped out
one
third of blindness just last week it was
announced
we can now take artificial corneas
and replace them and you have pure
eyesight back
that's a third of all blindness now over
we have to have the awe of what is
happening
but we also have to have the humility
and to ask why well you think i'm
this way why why do you believe that why
do you think that would be better
why do you not think this would be
better
once we get that mastered gratefulness
and why we put those two together we're
right back on track
and i think too glenn um it is curiosity
but also critical thinking
i mean that's just that's completely
dead in this society scientific method
right right there's just no critical
thinking not even just in science but
just
in society itself you know you're
talking about masks it's like people
would just rather comply
and go along with what someone else is
saying rather than
critically think about anything i think
it happens on all sides yes
cue come on use some critical thinking
here yeah you know
it's easy it's it's a it's an easy route
to answer some questions that
keep getting blocked but use some
critical thinking and
how many people even know what happened
yesterday with q
this morning about the uh the guy who
came out oh yeah it wasn't yesterday
it's okay if you there's a if the daily
podcast
for from the new york times he forces me
to listen to um
um but what's what's really happening
the trump level who are these people and
usually like they'll respond like
well they're all satanists
and they're they're sacrificing children
in the basement
fascinating i never looked at it that
way never a question
yeah never the crazy people you know uh
first on the on the y thing that you
just mentioned over christmas we were
in florida with my my niece she's five
years old and i was flipping through
netflix and she saw back to the future
she said what's that i so let's watch
back to the future
watch back to the future with the
five-year-old we're watching it she had
me pause that thing
literally 50 times to say why yeah why
why
why what and then i just buy the
greatest thing of children
because you know what happened by the
end i realized i can't explain anything
about it
i don't know what the hell is considered
i thought i'd tell you something one
point twenty-one gigawatts is they don't
even know i i will tell you
that because i i mean because
i've gone through what you've gone
through what everybody if conservatives
now going through yeah
i was the test rat yes for that system
and when you go through that you do
if you're if you're normal you do ask
yourself
do am i that way at all what makes
people think
this way and i came to the conclusion
that the problem that i have had
is when i'm certain
certitude is poisonous
and when you're certain of something
then no one has anything else to teach
you
and i've tried to adopt this this
mantra now for me if the only thing i'm
certain of
is that i'm not certain of anything and
i think that comes with
age and maturity as well that you know
you're so strident because
you know when you're when you're 15 i
i'm gonna live until i'm 30 but i'm
going out in the blaze of glory
you know what i mean you get to 29 and a
half yeah and you're like wait wait
you know and then you you just learn so
much and at some point
you get to a point to where you've seen
the cycle come and go and you're like
oh crap i'm still where i was when i was
15.
yeah you i don't know if you saw it but
well you guys of course all know you
know larry king who is my friend and
mentor and many ways he was like a
bonus grandfather i got in the middle of
my life so amazing i asked him
several times in interviewing him what
he thought the meaning of life was
that's exactly what he said
all i know is i don't know and this is a
guy who for as many people as we've all
interviewed this guy
interviewed everybody he heard every
religious perspective
he heard every uh secular perspective he
heard everything
and there was a humility to that that i
think really translated into his life
we only have like two minutes left um
we're going to be all right how about
that for a question
yeah that's in two minutes okay go yeah
uh
i i think so we're gonna be all right i
would like to believe so
i think it's gonna take i think it's
going to get worse before it gets better
yeah i think it's going to take more
than where we're at now but i i would
like to believe
in uh in humanity i would like to
believe in society i think eventually
it'll be
i think there's a four month old back
there that hopes you're right yes um
yeah well i guess i'll switch the
question a little bit how much worse do
you think it has to get before it gets
better because that really is the
question
yeah i mean um
certain things will get worse that we'll
notice very vividly
and a lot of things will get better that
we won't notice at all
and i think if over time that actually
is a positive gain but it's really hard
to see
and we should try to spend some more
time looking for it wow
let me end with a quote but i want to
change
the definition of a word before i give
it to you when i say
i i mean we
and there's a difference between us and
the audience
and that is this i have seen the
promised land
we will get to the promised land i
may not get there with you but we will
get to the promised land
amen and a woman
thanks to sarah stu and glenn and i'm
pretty sure if you go to blazetv.com
dave right now you get 30 bucks up
you're shut up that's the thing
to
is subscribing so you may as well thanks
for watching everybody get offline for
the weekend and i'll see you on monday